spider-man homecoming is here but then
spider-man homecoming has now officially
been released it's open it's out dear
you totally watch it I'm at a
commencement spider-man homecoming
spoiler talk because that's always fun
to gush about spoilers I couldn't talk
about my spoiler free review them being
spoilers and all and that is a spoiler
warning for people who haven't seen
spider-man homecoming if you have not
seen spider-man homecoming best to leave
now watch my spoiler free spider-man
homecoming review if you have seen it or
don't care about spoilers I welcome
welcome here my channel I'm not going to
give you a frame-by-frame play-by-play
we could talk about some of the spoilers
I couldn't talk about my spoiler free
review let's talk about how this movie
opens up I mean first of all like I said
you really emphasize where Adrian Toomes
who's the vulture empathized where he's
coming from because you put all this
money into this project where he's like
alright we're going to clean up the
streets not like from crime but from
debris that's right his company is going
to clean up the fallout from the alien
invasion battle from the first Avengers
movie can make a lot of money doing that
instead of shield or the government or
someone strolls there's like no you're
not we're going to do it you get boned
out of money so he's like world's
changing boys then we change too so
that's what they do they go to Avengers
battle sites and they scrape up all the
tech and they make new weapons and then
sell them on the street
great scene with donald glover which is
funny because when people heard Donald
Glover was going to be in the movies
like dude she's totally gonna be Miles
Morales now he's just a guy he's a guy
who wants a gun but when the Shocker is
showcasing the weapons it's blowing [ __ ]
and Happy's like yeah I just I just want
to hold someone up I don't want to blast
them back in time or something I was
funny when it starts out boom a film by
Peter Parker and he's just vlogging
shitty thing is they ruin that in the
trailer it was just a bummer I like
seeing it in the trailer but I just
sometimes I'm not forward-thinking
enough sometimes I'm not oh that's
totally going to ruin the experience
when I see it for the first time and
movie theater so when I saw it I was
like it's great but I have seen this
damnit Spider Man trailer stop that and
he's really antsy because Tony Stark's
like hey we'll call it yet and then a
couple months go by and nothing Peter
Parker wants to be spider-man he goes
out there and he's doing small things
getting cats out of trees saving bike
stopping a guy from breaking into his
own car which is pretty funny because
there's no manual to being a hero
especially when you're a teenage kid
you're a 15 year old teenage boy you're
going to screw up a lot but Tony Stark
is not calling him which is stupid you
have a really smart superfan you do not
blow that kid off that's how you create
supervillains his friend Ned very early
on finds out that he's spider-man just
saw him crawling
to the window again shown in the trailer
so at that point if friends kinda he
breaches on the grounds of being and
knowing who's asking him so many
questions about being spider-man granted
I'd probably do the same thing I
probably find when we're hanging out
then I'd grill him we can grill him in
the middle of class knowing it would
blow a secret identity I mean these kids
are nerds right like they're down with
comic books like I as one I would know
what you don't want to spoil that if
they don't have comic books in the comic
book world unless it's x-men unless it's
Logan about the scene in gym class
though where those kids were playing
merry [ __ ] kill just a few miners just a
few teenage girls playing marry [ __ ]
kill and a spider-man movie nothing
weird blond ones Betty Brant Elizabeth
Banks played her in the rainy spider-man
she's going to work for Jay jonah
jameson one day this Mommy has a lot of
great spider-man imagery it really does
like that scene where he's going to go
into the party and all debilities like
spider-man is not a party trick but he
wants to go in there to impress people
because Leo Peter Parker knows
spider-man so I was like oh yeah bring
spider-man's girl of course Peter Parker
sneaks LA he's in a spider-man outfit
and he's looking into the party and the
imagery is he's looking into the party
you see the back of him and from the
neck down he's in the spider-man outfit
and from the neck up he doesn't have the
mask on so with Peter Parker's head
spider-man suit looking into the party
the imagery is so completely spider-man
to me
I remember that's the kind of image I
saw he was in one of those view masters
from the 80s I knew of spider-man I knew
the stories I had a spider-man TV train
but when you're a little kid who would
you look like under that mask I bet he's
a really horrendous spider person well
then when I saw an image like that I was
like oh he's just a guy the image will
always stick with me so when I saw that
in the movie it's like the movie went
into my brain and pulled an image that
completely changed my perspective on
spider-man it threw it into this movie I
have to think I'm not the only one with
a moment like that for spider-man
imagery what do you think is a friend
Ned I read somewhere I literally when I
say I read somewhere online
someone tweeted it is Twitter chatter
goes it's just Twitter chatter but
someone said that his friend Ned is
supposed to be Ned Lee who's one of the
hobgoblins I don't see that by the
venture I guess I would say that dude is
not going to become the Hobgoblin
however if Peter Parker's friend Ned is
Ned Leeds
jr. and his father becomes the Hobgoblin
in a future spider-man movie cool it
does run into the thing that is
ultimately it's spider-man 101 at this
point Green Goblin is his best friend's
father if they go that route Hobgoblin
would be his
friend father and yes in this movie
Adrian Toomes aka the vulture is his
date's father as a girl is he has a
crush on the entire time because this is
a high school accommodate he finally
asked her to homecoming and when he
shows up to the door boom there he is
Michael Keaton answers the door my first
knee-jerk thought was oh my god he found
out who he was he has them all hostage
but it took a second I was like nope
these are dad I mean I should if you
spend like oh shoot he's her father
right out the gate but I didn't it was
even wearing his vulture getup
why would he be wearing flannel if he's
there as the vulture no he of course
he's her father
mine he's just raised in 100 miles an
hour all I'm saying is it caught me off
guard and I really like because he's
such a dad like when you're there Peter
Parker's just turning pale why it's like
the whole time you're like this guy is
ultimately Heisenberg he's doing what
he's doing for his family but you know
when he flips that switch man it's going
to be [ __ ] going down so when they're in
the car he just pieces the head [ __ ]
because I love the fact that he pieced
it together because it's so obvious it's
like oh yeah you were there at the
Washington Monument and then he
disappeared in the spider-man shioda
randomly and he's kind of just taking it
all in and he's like all right gumdrop
going I mean I have to give him the dad
dog and she goes in and then he has his
gun his Glock it he's leans over he's
like does she know I just really like
that thing he's pretty much like you're
going to go in there you're going to
sure a good time you're going to piss
off and just stay out of my business
funny thing is this next job is his last
job supposedly so if he just pissed off
it would just be one job I won't lie I
really thought about that just like dude
he just does one more job and they're
supposed to believe he's out and I am
really tossing in my friend it's like
what I just let him slide and let it go
I don't know and that's why Peter Parker
is a better person than me because as
Michael Keaton addresses in this movie
when he's talking to him he's like
you're young you don't know what it's
like and he's completely right Peter
Parker spider-man is young in this movie
15 years old he's not burdened with the
complications of adult life it's very
black-and-white like know these weapons
you're making our bad if he were older
he might be able to be like alright
you're doing this for your family and
you really got hosed by Tony Stark you
make a great point when you say Tony
Stark also sold weapons I thought we'd
got his fortune it might have been a
different conversation if Peter Parker
were older it's all I'm saying but he's
young he's a bit naive in that that's
what makes him glorious he's like no
it's bad you're going down and
when that building falls on him I love
this scene because he's so completely a
kid he just gets crushed by this ceiling
any screaming he's like he's crying you
feel so bad for him you're like - you
are so out of your league here Tony
Stark say you're nothing without the
suit then you shouldn't have it which is
the new mantra it's a new with great
power comes great responsibility thing
something he's going to remember that
will keep him going in the toughest time
Tony Stark told him that when he totally
screwed the pooch and had a [ __ ] blow in
half you saw it all in the trailer I
don't need to talk about it here exactly
what you saw is what happened funny is
he does a solid push-up and throws that
roof off of them and you know the
spider-man versus vulture happens but I
thought that was so good it's just a
good moment it such a good moment of
seeing him as a vulnerable kid but also
seeing him as the hero that is a better
person than I go in a different
direction with Flash Thompson I found
that interesting Flash Thompson was
always the jock bully that's the high
school cliche that I always knew was
like jock bully nerd the jocks pick on
the Nerds and I've been out of high
school for a little while maybe it's
changed but I like the fact that Flash
Thompson the bully is actually part of
Peter Parker's social group you can't
run from someone like that it's a dick
who's a part of your social circle one
thing I will give props on the amazing
spider-man that they did is Flash
Thompson is a spider-man fan who doesn't
like Peter Parker that's the irony
so it's interesting in spider-man
homecoming - or spider-man whatever they
call it I want to see a flash Thompson
is a fan of spider-man wasn't out on the
Xoom daya MJ reveal saying the reason
I'm not is this her character was fine
and she was good in the role for what
she was doing she was her own character
and it was Michelle or something like
that I was totally fine with that she's
a snarky kind of dick that would be fun
to hang out with but you feel like she's
totally friends done with Peter Parker
you do not feel any romantic connection
at all between these two so in that I
was fine with her being Peter Parker's
friend but now at the end she's like Oh
Michelle my friends call me MJ I was
like why do you have to be MJ why can't
you just be Michelle I don't see why
they had to go such a different
direction with Mary Jane it's like
making Peter Parker's friend Ned be like
all my friends call me Harry Osborn I
just why don't do that make him it and
make her Michelle I feel like the plan
wasn't to make her MJ funding of all the
rumors that came out like who is in days
she Mary Jane they were like no she is
not Mary Jane swear I can we speak and
they weren't lying because her name is
not Mary Jane it's Michelle whose
friends call her MJ but it kind of feels
like the whole MJ thing was a complete
afterthought
she was her own character then the rumor
came out they were like no she's not mad
at you wait a minute we can make her MJ
let's shoot a scene where we fill that
in all right sweet afterthought so I
wasn't digging that but we'll see how
the sequel goes and may notice Peter
Parker spider-man there is no hiding
that [ __ ] now didn't get that from a
Halloween store or something no that
costume is legit and of course there are
a couple post-credit scenes first ones
in jail and shows Adrian Toomes he's
walking up to I believe it's scorpion
what do you think about this movie has a
lot of side spider-man villains that you
don't actually know where they're
shockers a bit obvious I heard the dude
who makes everything's the tinkerer I
don't really know who the tinkerer is
the dude who's talking Adrian Toomes in
jail has a scorpion tattooed like a
scorpion he's like rumor is you know who
spider-man is Michael Keaton's like if I
knew he'd already be dead which maybe he
did it for the greater good because he
saved his daughter's life probably not
he didn't tell them if he crossed me
again I'm going to kill you and everyone
you care about and he crossed him again
so I feel like that's going to go down
feel like he just kept it to himself
because when he gets out of there he's
going to want to kill him and it looks
like oh my gosh they might be setting up
a sinister six movie in a proper way and
the second post-credit scene is great
the first one was you know story based
second one is straight up a joke but
it's hysterical this right Captain
America has his PSA videos which when I
saw those in the trailer I was like
isn't that dude kind of not in with the
US government right now a Civil War
thing he was on the opposing side and
sure enough but he's like all right
you're in gym class gym teacher turns it
off he's like I'm pretty sure that guy's
a war criminal now anyways whatever glad
they address that but one of those PSAs
comes on for you the audience in Captain
America goes we're going to talk about
something important patience sometimes
you wait around for something that just
doesn't quite happen the way you think
it should sometimes patients just
doesn't pay off it was just funny
because everyone waits through the end
credits and then gets a lesson about
patience and how they wasted their time
staring all I thought that was really
funny I saw a few people in the comment
section of my last video when I said
there's a movie reference that happens
and then the movie addresses that yes it
is a movie reference to that's when he's
running across the lawns and it's a
tracking shot wait then I was like this
looks a lot like Ferris Bueller's Day
Off and that dudes on the grill and he's
like smells great I was like that is a
lot like various Beeler's he shows a
clip of that scene from Ferris Bueller's
Day Off and he swings by the pulleys
like that's a great movie splashy's gun
thought that was awesome that dude on
the grill looked a lot like Cameron Frye
by the way
look it up on IMDB he's not listed as an
all I'm saying is dude on the grill in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off reference looks
a lot like Cameron fry from Ferris
Bueller's Day Off guys in the end
spider-man homecoming was still great
the second time I saw it actually I'm
able to appreciate a movie more the
second time because I'm not you know
picking it apart looking for things to
critique for a review I get to sit back
and just kind of enjoy myself a little
more what do I like more spider-man 2 or
Spider Man homecoming poor guys really I
don't know I watched spider-man 2 last
night I watched spider-man homecoming
tonight so they're both fresh in my mind
spider-man 2 does have things you look
at now that didn't age as well as you
would hope they would just logic things
like Spider Man should be able to lay
out Doc Ock with one punch oh yeah you
didn't get super-strength you just got
arms now you're unconscious but as a
movie as a whole a fantastic spider-man
homecoming is fantastic I won't be able
to assess which one is better for about
a decade so I'll get back to you on that
but now the spider-man homecoming is out
spider-man homecoming have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your order of the spider-man movies
greatest to leave whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]